today is Thursday which usually means
that
adora or myself sit up here with someone
notable and have a hopefully interesting
conversation the someone notable we have
today is Andy Bromberg my friend and the
president of coin list the president and
co-founder of coin list which is this
really fascinating company that is doing
some interesting things will talk about
but Andy maybe we can start by you
talking a little bit about your your
entrepreneurial background because
interestingly even though you graduated
from Stanford a couple years ago coin
list isn't your first venture is it
that's right so first of all thank you
for having me and thank you everyone for
coming this is gonna be a lot of fun the
entrepreneurial background for me
started even before school in high
school it's one of the people that
started some web design and marketing
businesses nothing really notable but I
think it was really valuable to get that
initial experience of building something
and hiring a team and managing a team
and firing people and figuring out how
to how did you do all those things while
you were in high school I did yeah I got
started was a lot of fun what what made
you do that at like what was it about
being an entrepreneur and that that
attracted you while you're still in high
school
got in high school I was I was worried
about other things it was really nothing
about being an entrepreneur and more
about not wanting to do other jobs that
I was able to do when I was in high
school you know you can sit there and
you can do whatever sir pizza or scoop
ice cream or whatever it is I worked in
a supermarket yeah that was awesome I
did the scooping ice cream too
yeah it was fun but I was looking at it
and saying like all these businesses in
my town have awful websites and I've got
a bunch of friends that do this stuff in
their spare time and that seems like
just a way better way to make a little
bit of money while I'm in high school
then you know circle pizza and so I went
and did that and expanded out videos
marketing photos all that stuff ran a
few websites that did pretty well but it
was really less of I want to be an
entrepreneur and more of I really don't
want to do these other jobs and it then
developed into a love for building
things from the ground up and trying to
create but at the time it was it was
purely an alternative nada
not a primary so did you
so you really weren't thinking of this
as like I'm an entrepreneur and I'm
gonna be like my family's been
entrepreneurs forever it was more an
escape an alternate route from sort of
the normal high school I'm gonna get
some some maybe not so interesting job
and do something more interesting and
probably you made a lot more money doing
it too yeah absolutely and I think and
not to fall into some of the the
immediate kind of startup cliches but I
was doing stuff that I really enjoyed
doing I was hanging out with my friends
and building things which was really fun
I enjoyed that we built a bunch of
websites around just things that we
liked and it wasn't necessarily that
we're looking at it and saying you know
I'm gonna analyze this opportunity and
do my Tam calculation and figure out
this and the business strategy we just
said I love playing soccer what if I
made a website that reviewed soccer
cleats alright let's do that we made one
of those did really well what you know I
like messed around with computers let's
build one around you know how to how to
dig into the internals of a Mac and do
things with it let's build that that's
it pretty well it was really based on
these things that we just enjoyed doing
we had figured out how to do and want it
to build these sites around our passions
I'm intrigued so this was going pretty
well you're you're probably senior in
high school you um get into a little
school on the west coast did you ever
have the thought like I'm not going to
Stanford I'm gonna just I'm gonna like I
am the next whatever Mark Zuckerberg I'm
going yeah I don't I think those really
truly would have been kind of delusions
of grandeur at that point they were
these were like little things they were
fun and they made money and I you know
covered my expenses and was able to do
what I wanted to do but it was not none
of these were going to be massive
businesses and sure of course the
thought occurs you're like I could just
keep doing this I'm surviving on this
this would be fun but ultimately I got a
great opportunity to go to a go to great
school and decided to do that and
continue to do them for a little while
while I was there and did some of that
stuff but kind of trailed off during a
couple years I was there and and and
then eventually kind of tailed off
completely well but the idea of starting
companies didn't because apparently the
bug hit you again while you were at
Stanford right yeah that's right so so I
was I was there for a couple years had a
lot of fun really actually the most
impactful bit there was
tied into this whole entrepreneurship
thing which is I took this amazing class
when I was there I'm called startup
engineering from a guy named Paul DS
furnivall son who's now the the CTO of
coin basin formerly see over and calm
and formally a partner andreessen
horowitz and founder of counsel amazing
guy who actually lectured at the very
first ever startup school and and he
taught this class about you know I think
a lot of times university classes aren't
on entrepreneurship don't teach you the
real skills you need to start a business
he might teach you some really high
level things or really basic
fundamentals but nothing around the the
pragmatic steps and he set out to build
a class much like this one that said
know if you're actually going to do this
what you need to do there's a lot of
time with guest lecturers coming to
classes a lot of time with you know
things like it was a computer science
class how do you deploy code how do you
you know do revision control on code and
how do you put on github and how do you
do these different things the practical
pieces and we took this class a bunch of
us and had an amazing time and actually
out of that which will come full circle
back to this a small set of folks that
were in that class ended up founding the
Stanford Bitcoin group back in 2012-2013
I hope they bought some Bitcoin not
enough ever enough but yeah so he
convinced us all you know this Bitcoin
thing is gonna be real at the time we're
looking at him and saying no way I mean
this is 2012 were like this Bitcoin is
magic Internet money I don't believe you
for a second this doesn't work and and
he said come on let's do it and so we
started the stand for Bitcoin group and
spent a couple years in school doing a
lot of Awesome research and evangelism
and had a lot of fun running around you
know teaching people about crypto and
building things or researching things
but then yeah ultimately I did end up
leaving to start start a different
company and left even that behind well
so that different company was side wire
which interestingly seems like it's more
relevant today maybe more than Bitcoin
because it was all about like real news
right yeah so I built this platform
called side wire and I I left school in
2014 to start this company and I left
early because I found what I think is
the perfect partner for it my co-founder
Tucker good background in politics and I
had this background in computer science
building things we came together to
this product that was a platform where
the experts in politics could chat
publicly about the news of the day and
everyone else could read and engage but
not participate on that same level we
wanted to build a Twitter without the
noise what if you took just the experts
and put them in conversation with each
other and we did this really around the
2016 election there was 2014 - we ended
up winding it down last year 2017 but it
sounds like we need it really badly I
think we still do it you know I talked
to a lot of people that are building
similar products trying to separate out
the signal from the noise and hopefully
some of you in here or online are
working to do that - because I think
it's such a critical problem turns out
very hard problem a variety of reasons
but I think it's it's critical that
someone solve it so maybe for the
benefit of these folks and never fear we
will we will talk about crypto TED talk
a little bit if you would about the
process of starting the company you left
school to do it and and and the winding
down like what happened and and and
maybe if there's some lessons learned in
there
from that experience yeah absolutely the
starting was was really it always is
kind of the best part when you have this
germ of an idea and you're trying to
turn it into something and so we started
Tucker and I met and started talking
were introduced by a mutual friend named
Adam well I was still in school we
started talking about this concept that
there's this crazy noise level in the
discourse today especially on politics
and other topics we separate that out
with a lot of different ideas around how
to do it and iterate it through a
million different things and and
ultimately he was working at that time a
great job I was in school we're looking
at it as I'm sure many people are saying
and this is a big leap to take to go
from very comfortable situations out a
couple years left school he was again
doing great at work you could make this
leap and so we said all right we have a
we got to a place where you know nine
months in a kind of casual discussion so
we're both working and learning we said
we think we know what we want to do here
and the timing was I mean was great
we're looking at this this is right
before summer 2014 so we know I've got
some lead time up into the elections to
build stuff and then launch into the
election cycle
we thought we knew what we wanted to
build and so we said alright well we
need to get some validation for this
before we get going which was just the
the state of mind that we were and I
don't think this is always true for
entrepreneurs by any means but our state
was you know we're both in great
positions this is gonna be really hard
let's get some validation so we went out
said we're gonna raise some money and if
we can successfully raise that money
let's go and do it and the the
commitment kind of was that if we could
do that before the summer I would go
obviously over my summer and working at
full time and then beyond and he would
leave the job and go and and and we do
it together and so we're able to put
together that money and get that
validation and start building did you
race from angels then yeah almost
entirely from angels yeah and we had an
amazing set of investors lesson learned
and thankfully we didn't learn it in the
negative way having great investors is
such a boon throughout the business and
things run well and when things are on
poorly we'll get to the wine town but
even that part having an amazing set of
investors that were aligned with us
cared about us as people and you know
we're support of what we were doing was
so critical at that point and really
digging it on on what their motivations
were was was really important see we
raise from a lot of people we had I
forget the exact number now but
something like 44 investors in our seed
round or something like that ever think
that maybe that was too many yes and no
the only time I ever genuinely I never
really want to turn down money right
yeah the only time I genuinely thought
that was too many was when I was dealing
with meeting all of them to sign things
but but generally again it goes back to
the quality of the investors they were
supportive and not annoying and never
nagged us and we sent out our monthly
updates and you know made sure they were
informed and it was never a problem it
was just yeah sending out 44 Dawn's a
lot of DocuSign son send out but imagine
one one issue with like 40 or 50 or 60
investors is that even if you really try
to only get high quality investors the
probability that one or two of those are
difficult gets pretty high yeah
absolutely and of course even within
that set of 44 there was a spectrum of
people ranging from absolutely perfect
to slightly less perfect but but on the
whole it was a really great set and
we're fortunate to be
by them and so we ended up doing that
and and the the short story on the
company is we've built for about a year
and then we kind of raised the last part
of that round it was all one big round
but raised last part of that round from
spark capital who were amazing investors
highly recommend working with them and
they kind of completed our institutional
seed round and then we launched the
product and ran it for a couple years
and ultimately wound it down last summer
yeah 22:17 mid-2017 I think from a
product perspective just just just
before you get there yeah so you went
all the way through the 2016
presidential cycle did you guys have any
insight more than the rest of us about
what was going to happen in November
2016 based on yeah the discussions that
we're taking place I can say and things
I can't say but the yeah what you know
we're talking to a lot of things you
can't say exactly there's there's a lot
of smart people out there and and this
ties in to what side water was able to
do but also kind of who we were talking
to you we got the this amazing set of
experts in the platform engaging like
crazy but a thousand people senators
presidential candidates reporters
analysts staffers all the people you
would want to have talking the really
smart voices the smart commentators
having these amazing discussions going
back and forth firing back and forth
being entertaining and and and we felt
like that side it's a marketplace right
you'd supply of content and demand
content no one is paying but you know
supply and demand we crush the supply
and just no matter what we did we
couldn't get people to pay attention to
it which we thought was so interesting
so our thesis going in and I think a lot
of times startups about having a thesis
and testing it but a thesis we felt
really strongly about it wasn't so far
as build and they will come but we
thought this is a marketplace a two
sided marketplace if we can get the
supply if we can get smart people to
have smart conversations about the news
of the day then we will be able to get
people that show up to stick around and
keep engaging with those conversations
and reading them no matter what we
didn't there's no way to know what the
issue was we could not get people to
come and stick around and you know
people would show up and read one
conversation and then would not come
back and I think it
the day what we felt like was you know
in that space people it's hard to get
people to care about the smart
conversations it's not people say that's
what they're looking for and and it
might not actually be what drives them
and what they actually want they want
140 or 280 characters of sensational
tweets yeah yeah and and I I hope that
that's not true and I hope that we had
issues with the product that we're
deeper than that or something like that
that caused it to not be effective in
retaining users but at the end of the
day we had a really tough time even
given just a stream of crazy high
quality content from the best people in
the world on these topics it's tough to
talk together as people with sticker
okay so this is this is a tough question
for any startup to answer which is at
some point you decided it wasn't an
issue of tweaks it wasn't an issue of
being able to find product market fit
that this you could you could pivot 10
degrees 20 degrees 180 degrees it wasn't
going to happen and you wound the
company down how did how did you guys
come to that decision yes so we we did
try a couple other related but more more
than ten or twenty four twenty degree
tweaks but related topics you know a
subscription service we tried for a
little bit and pitched some enterprise
related things ultimately we decided
that what we were looking at the
possibilities we were looking at even if
they succeeded couldn't be venture scale
businesses that we need it to be betting
on and it's these are conversations we
had with our investors super honest
transparent conversations with them with
our team with each other and we said
alright well you know the business our
core business that we've envisioned and
been working on for two three years
don't think that one's gonna work at
least you know with it without some
crazy change and how people are thinking
or us having some insane inside of
fixing something that's terribly broken
these other businesses were looking at
other business lines there's a
possibility but these aren't the type of
returns that we're looking for our
investors are looking for when we
started this business and and so at that
point we said all right instead of you
know trying to keep this thing on
life-support let's wind it down and move
to our next thing and and keep building
from there and it was a decision that
everyone was incredibly supportive of
again this goes right back to the good
investor thing it is easy for people to
give you a lot of grief when you make a
decision like that but we were
incredibly fortunate to have an amazing
investors that supported us in that okay
last question on side where do you think
if you could have persuaded President
Trump to call you fake news you might
have been able to survive you know it's
that we've talked about that a lot um I
I don't think so I it's it's so bizarre
and you know we could talk for hours
about this but people would show up and
engage and then they just kind of like
disappear
they'd be like this just doesn't it
didn't doesn't do it for me and we
talked to people and they'd say yeah oh
it's great I like the contents really
good I just I would never like you know
go and read it on there like really pick
it up in him you know there's not a lot
of people out there that pick up the New
York Times every day and read it
cover-to-cover and that's effectively
the same type of person that we were
looking for someone that cared about
that one you have to somehow make it a
habit this is true for any startup you
have to somehow create enough value so
that you get integrated into people's
lives and it's hard to do that with news
and I do think like that you alluded to
the like people want 140 or 280
characters of crazy stuff sure there's
an element of that that is people want
the crazy things that just spew up fake
news this big news that whatever it is
but the other piece of that is that it's
easiest to create a habit with something
that's bite-sized and what we were
asking people to do was read a real
conversation it was kind of like a I
message format like people going back
and forth and having these back-forth
conversations it's not bite-sized takes
you a few minutes to read if not longer
to read these really engaging ones and
there's smart people saying smart things
you got to think about what they're
saying and jumping from not engaging
with a service to engage in with a long
conversation you have to read it's a big
jump to make and so I think yet to your
point building habits is so crucial and
habits are easiest started with
something very small that might
eventually expand to something big and
think about how much time
many people spend on Facebook but it
often starts with something really small
there to build that habit Facebook has
great things around you know you sign up
it's connect with ten friends they've
got these like numbers if you need to do
this you need to do that it's all easy
it's all limited time and then the habit
starts get ingrained and you can build
it out bigger from there okay so let's
let's transition to talk about
and II Bromberg phase 2.5 where you went
back a little bit to I would say a
crypto roots but back to some of the
some of the work you'd been doing
earlier it's at Stanford and got
involved with I guess nammal and an
angel list and an eventually COI list
how did that transpire yeah so even to
take a step further back than that when
I left school in 2014 I was crazy
interested in crypto spending a ton of
time on it with the the Stanford Bitcoin
group my friends and people in the
industry and the reason I didn't feel
comfortable doing anything in crypto at
that time was because of a secular issue
for me which was at that point 2014 I
couldn't make a decision if I was a coin
flip whether or not there was gonna be
one cryptocurrency forever Bitcoin was
gonna be it and that was gonna be the
end of it or if there were gonna be a
ton of cryptocurrencies out there and I
was looking at it and saying startups
high failure rate already do I want to
add a 50% coin flip to that because
anything I could think of betting on
relied on one of those two outcomes and
I said I I don't want to add 50% more to
an already high attrition rates I'm
gonna not do this for now by the time it
came back end of lather good news
attrition rates so high that 50% hardly
makes a difference double double your
chance of failures is hard I want to
take off and yeah and so I you know 2017
I'm looking at it and saying up I'm now
a believer there's going to be at least
more than one who knows how many
successful crypto currencies in the long
run we can talk more about what that
number might be and how we should think
about that but I feel comfortable going
back to the space now and the story with
coin list is that coin was started about
a year ago just over a year ago we just
celebrated our internal one-year
anniversary and it was created as a
collaboration between protocol labs
proud Y Combinator company and an angel
list to run protocol labs token sale for
their product file coin for their token
file corn and I think I think that you
have to unpack that a little bit because
I was trying to think about how
hopefully a lot of the people here and
out there have understand crypto
currencies and there's lots and lots and
lots and lots that's been
written and said about them but maybe we
can sort of very briefly outline what a
cryptocurrency is what a token sale is
what a token is and why you might be
selling them yeah yeah everyone yes you
know at its core yeah exactly at its
core a token is a scarce digital asset
we'll talk more about what each of these
things mean a scarcity lasts that that
represents ownership most commonly of a
token network so the idea here is that
when you launch a token network it goes
out and no one then controls it so
bitcoin is a lot of you know was created
by the pseudonym Satoshi Nakamoto and if
that's a he or she or a single person or
a group of people no one knows who
Satoshi is and somehow she's weird right
like you make this this really important
thing that's made and and lost fortunes
for people and maybe will be the basis
of the future economy no one knows where
it came from weird right yeah like
really let that settle it's worth like a
hundred billion dollars right now the
total market cap of Bitcoin and no one
knows who made it and in fact Satoshi
has some large number of tokens socked
away in a wallet somewhere that has
never been used
we have billions of dollars worth of
Bitcoin we have no idea who has that
literally no idea if anyone has anyone
right and so that is kind of the
ultimate ideal how to think about it
that that's possible you can launch this
token network and have it go out into
the world and have nobody control it and
it just kind of happens and so what
these companies are now doing when they
launch these new tokens like protocol
labs launching file coin their intention
is to build a network got a lot of code
to write they've got to build this thing
and they're gonna put it out there into
the world and they're of course going to
continue to support it as you know core
developers of the product and improve
the network but they won't actually have
control over at the users whoever those
users may be in whatever categories they
may fit into that specific network are
the ones that have control of it well
talk about what protocol Labs was doing
because because the token is that
protocol Labs is first token that coin
list was working on was was not like you
could say bitcoin is a value you know
itself it's like a new currency but the
token
for protocol Labs was inextricably
linked to a different value that was
being delivered to consumers right yeah
yeah we should talk about that one other
thing I want to mention just on tokens
in general and this analogy is a little
bit of use but there's one reason I'd
use it I would think of tokens and
blockchain technology which powers many
tokens like the internet for one really
core reason if I asked you hey Jeff I've
got a website and here's a bunch of data
about it how do you value it it's
impossible to answer that question
because if that website is nytimes.com
or amazon.com or google.com or
facebook.com those are all totally
different businesses they were all built
on the Internet
sure but you look at each of their
revenues they've got different multiples
how do you think about how these
businesses are built saying how do you
value a website is kind of a meaningless
question you have to know much more
about the specific use case and how it's
built and in the same way I think
there's a lot of discussion I get the
question a ton from people okay but how
do we value these tokens and to me
that's a little bit of an impossible
question because tokens are built on
different premises and of different
applications and you can break them down
into categories that go to how to value
each of those categories in the same way
you could say well how do we value a
social networking website or how do we
value a news website or how do we value
you know a CPG website but you have to
think about those categories and the
idea of a token or blockchain technology
is really just this kind of meta concept
it allows for other things to be built
on top of it and and one more piece of
that analogy would be yeah I draw a
similarity between the Internet is
infrastructure for exchanging and
transacting information it moves
information around tokens and token
networks are infrastructure for
transacting or exchanging value so for
the first time we can actually kind of
programmatically exchange value in this
in this core way what are the strange
things about the whole conversation so
so here's how I would answer your your
question about how to value a website
and actually is the way people have
always valued things which is well I
would say huh let tell me about the cash
flows that that website will generate
over time and then historically we've
figured out ways to value those things
using things like net present value and
all these
these economic concepts but tokens seem
somehow different because they don't
necessarily seem to be tied to cash
flows see yes let's talk about file coin
like you were saying it just as an
example and this is again just one
example of many in one of many
categories
I'll give kind of a quick description of
file coin and how it works we can go
into it more in the QA so file coin is a
token that allows for the exchange of
file storage of files it's aiming to
sort solve this problem of how do you
store files and transact that until the
market for storing files and so if you
think about the simplest solution to how
would one build a business to solve that
problem the simplest solution probably
looks something like Amazon s3 if Jeff
has files that he wants to store and I'm
say I'm gonna start a business that
helps him store these files I'm probably
gonna buy a bunch of servers and Jeff's
gonna hand me files I'm gonna put them
on the servers when he asked for them
back I'm gonna hand them back and he's
gonna pay me so that that works bigness
today built like that but it has a few
problems so one you've got someone
that's taking fees I'm charging on top
of the storage costs for him to be able
to do this but there's also issues of
things like censorship so I now have
access to his files I can censor them I
can look at them I can do whatever I
want to them and you're relying on a
single third party not to mess anything
up so I could corrupt the files I might
have downtime and not be able to return
them and see you start say well is there
a better solution than this and the
first version of a better solution I
think looks a lot like kind of the
Airbnb of file storage where you'd say
all right well instead there's a whole
bunch of people out there who have extra
storage space in their computers
yeah raise your hand if you have extra
storage space on your computer you're
not seriously raise your hand come on
all of you you all have extra space no
your computers are full okay let's do it
we're pivoting so you know I would say
maybe all right well now Geoff Hammil
your files I'm gonna find someone out
here I'm connected to all of you I've
got software on your computers I'm gonna
put the files on your computer and then
you know Jeff wants them back I'll ask
in the back I'll take them I'll give
them to him he'll pay me I'll pay you
okay so these people
the few people who raised their hand so
we'll rent like Airbnb they'll rent a
piece of their stores that are not using
to the network so that so that's a good
solution but it doesn't solve all the
problems we talked about it does first
of all make it a little bit cheaper most
likely because this is kind of late and
storage space is cheaper than buying new
servers but still there's a middleman
right there's an intermediary me who
could go down I could have downtime I
could sense where the file is gonna look
at them
so you're still trusting someone so file
coin protocol Labs building file coin
and the underlying thing called ipfs the
interplanetary file system does the
coolest name for a file system ever said
is there a way to solve this can we
connect Jeff directly to people out here
who have extra storage space with no
trusted intermediary that's the problem
that by Allah coin is trying to solve
they build this token for a few reasons
one file coin is used as the mechanism
of payment so Jeff pays you to store his
files with file coin but there's a
couple interesting problems we have to
solve first of all what if one of you
does something bad you corrupt his files
you lose them you don't return them fast
enough so there's first step of the
solution is to make each of you that is
storing his files for him already have
file coin so if you have extra storage
space you already have to a file coin
and you do what's called staking you
take those tokens and you put them up
effectively in escrow and you say here
I'm putting my own tokens up and putting
something at stake and if I get caught
doing something wrong if I don't return
his files fast enough I don't you know
return them at all then I lose my tokens
so you are disincentivized from doing
something bad to Jeff's files that's
interesting
step number one you're on to the second
problem which is who's the judge of that
if we're not trusting a central
intermediary how do we know if you are
not storing the files well or corrupting
them or how do we know if you're not
returning them fast enough and that's
where it's step two of this really
interesting solution comes into play
which is that there's a massive network
outside of this room thousands of people
of what they call verifiers
I'm gonna oversimplify what they do a
little bit because they have this crazy
thing called proof of space-time over
the top you talk for hours about it but
a simple solution for how to make sure
that each of you is storing his files
correctly is that a thousand different
people come to Jeff and they each say to
Jeff hey Jeff what's the 46th letter of
your file what's the hundred and twenty
seventh letter of your file what's one
hundred and ninety-six letter of your
file and Jeff says
it says J a and K right and they go to
each person that store in the files and
ask that exact same question that person
who asked about the 47th letter says hey
what's the 47th letter of the file
you're storing you answer that J and
they check a K and now all of a sudden
when enough verifiers do that we can say
with confidence that the person storing
the files for Jeff is doing so correctly
and at that point the network says great
job everyone
Jeff pays you for storing his files you
get your state two tokens back Jeff gets
his files if he wants them and the
verifiers get rewarded by the by
effectively mining new tokens are minted
by the network and given to the
verifiers for doing that work which
makes the supply of coins expand over
time exactly and so then you have this
market where each of these three parties
the person with the files the person
with the storage space in these
verifiers are all incentivized to do the
right thing disincentivize we're doing
the wrong thing and there is no trusted
intermediary and you avoid all those
problems I sided with the S three
example at the beginning and that that
really gets to the core of what this all
is and I'll I'll stop rambling in a
second here but block chains and tokens
are about incentive alignment it's about
this question of how can you build a
trust list system a system where no
party has to trust any other party in a
system without anyone being involved in
managing that and the way to do that is
to properly incentivize everyone and
build these economic systems that allow
for that interaction to happen and it I
think that's one of the best
articulations I've heard I've heard of
what the blockchain based tokens are
about incentive alignment but they're
about one more thing isn't it true that
they're also about removing aligning the
incentives of the folks in the network
so that you can remove the central
authority so that you can remove Amazon
in the s2 case or the United States
government the Fed in the Bitcoin
case right right and that's that's for
any number of reasons and that goes back
to could be for pricing reasons it could
be at the middleman is charging fees
that are unreasonable could be for
censorship reasons in the domain of
censoring it could be for fear of
surveillance it could be for any number
of reasons but ultimately the most
common and effective use of these
blockchain systems is to yes remove that
middleman and make it
this trustless system can exist just
between the counterparties that need to
be involved in a transaction kind of the
ultimate ultimately Democratic version
of networking right markets for
everything yeah so so everyone out here
in start-up school world might be asking
themselves cool crypto cool tokens what
does that have to do with me what what
does this have to do with startups and
and you know we um
you know I've talked a bit about the
history of investing in we've come to
this place where where tokens are in
fact an important component of of how
startups raise money and and exist maybe
you can talk a little bit about this
this evolution to where I SEOs initial
coin offerings and the role coin list is
playing yeah so so it probably a little
bit of an unusual perspective here right
yeah
coin list we run token sales we make
money when people work with us to run
their token sales that's great I think
today token sales are a good idea for an
incredibly incredibly incredibly small
number of companies I think of the
twenty-seven thousand is that right
companies in start-up school there may
be a few where it's a really good idea
for a token to exist
not all 27 thousand today there are
cases I can make four in the future and
making sense for a broader set but today
I think it's a very small number just
give you a data point on that coin lists
we've existed for about a year
we've publicly worked with five token
sales in the last year we have had
inbound people asking us to work with
them more than 2,500 token sales and
that's not a it's not a bandwidth issue
that's not you know it's not being able
to service that that's us sitting there
and saying yeah these 2495 tokens not a
good fit for us and that that's kind of
it that's like like like the one of the
largest euphemisms not a good fit for
you meaning maybe not quite legit maybe
so so there's certainly a large set we
see of scams and spam and frauds and
people that are you know bad actors or
just how much how much just to riff on
that for one second how much has been
raised on icos and 2018 thus far yeah
very it's a tough industry to study but
probably somewhere around 15 billion
dollars it's a big number more than
venture capital just just to repeat that
in case someone maybe didn't hear that
clearly more money has been raised in
ICO than has been delivered in venture
capital to companies in 2018 thus far
yeah and and some people look at that
and say wow what a great sign for the
ICO industry we are thriving I look at
that and say that seems really
concerning to me because venture capital
has been around for as we've talked
about before almost a century of like
real kind of true development and
venture capital especially for
technology companies pretty well
developed industry we figured out kind
of the norms and how these things need
to be created the idea that ICS have
really only existed for four years and
really in kind of their mass for about
two years the idea that we could surpass
that so quickly in that stage of
development I see is actually a more
concerning thing than a positive thing
for the ICO industry one thing it shows
is demand because these are proxies for
investing in startups but it also I
guess shows a propensity for people to
believe things that maybe they shouldn't
be believing yeah I think that's right
now
you know it's also just a function about
being a new industry that its brand new
it's really hard to diligence for these
investors there aren't norms there's no
data points right now on what tokens are
successful and which ones aren't we're
so early into the industry and that's
it's not because everything's failed
it's because it's just too early to know
and so investors don't have a good sense
for how to do diligence I think about
you know understanding what they
represent right because at least if
you're buying a penny stock you still
know that that penny stock represents a
claim on the future cash flows or that
company in one way or another admittedly
that is a theoretical thing but at least
it's grounded in something concrete a
lot of times these I SEOs aren't rounded
in anything but I also I don't think it
has to necessarily be quantitative I
think about the YC process for admitting
companies and all the data you guys have
on years of startups and what succeeds
and what does and what are positive
signals and what are and how you look
through those applications that you just
can't do that
in tokens right now there's no training
data to look at and so that's resulted
in this kind of we've got to be over
the aggressive mentality from investors
of let's get in let's get in these
things gonna make us rich that's I think
pumped up the amount of money that has
gone into the space past where it really
reasonably should be and it may be that
that's an important step in the cut in
the industry's development do you need
this kind of huge infusion of capital to
give the winners enough money to start
to win and then you can sort out how do
diligence it better going forward but
certainly the vast majority of that
money that has gone into icos
is going into I SEOs that are not going
to be successful so just for for the
edification of everyone here could you
just step back and say what is what's an
ICO so what are these token things
what does coin list like why would you
use coin list
I can't you just do it and and and then
maybe we can transition to like to
answer the question you sort of talk
about ladies who should think about
doing an icy on who shouldn't yeah so
and just on terminology for folks that
are kind of newer to this space I tend
to use tokens coins cryptocurrencies all
synonymously crypto assets even some
people have slightly different
definitions I tend to use them all the
same and then I see oh token sale kind
of the same thing in my eyes so those
are generally synonymous an ICO or a
token sale is ico initial coin offering
is when a new network is being created
and a company is issuing tokens for the
first time in this network concerned to
distribute them and they've run this
token sale to do two things generally
one to raise money for the future
development of that network and support
that network in the long term and two to
get early distribution of those tokens
because these networks like vile coin
only works if there are people who have
it to store files people who have it to
you know give files to be stored and and
kind of incentive alignment around that
so you need a way to distribute these
tokens initially one way to do so is to
sell them and so they they go out and
conduct these sales where they go and
sell tokens to investors or to users
that want to eventually participate on
the net right and that's a case where
the the network literally does not work
unless you have a token yeah that's
exactly right
and so while chrome is the first token
sale that we supported a coin list they
raised a staggering two hundred and five
million dollars in their initial coin
offering and we've worked a number of
other ones
since block stack and props in origin
trust token and what coinless does is
for that small set of companies we
support the logistics of the token sale
so there's a bunch of compliance work
you need to do which is probably not
worth getting into but you'll hear these
buzzwords know your customer kyc anti
money laundering
you need lawyers to be involved and and
we have many of them and and so we you
know handle the compliance we had all
the transactions have payments work and
money comes in we handled you have to
know how this is gonna work with the SEC
cuz they're they're going to be already
are intimately involved right lots of
open regulatory questions lots of closed
regulatory questions you need to know
how to be able to answer correctly and
we support these companies that process
and then we'll you know market some of
these deals publicly or offer them to
the investors on our platform to be able
to invest in we also have four other
services like that just compliance piece
without the marketing as much we do for
a broader set of token issuers this
whole other airdrops product to give
tokens away to users um so you'll start
hearing this buzzword airdrops more and
more I think this is a way of giving so
we talked about icos being a way to
fundraise and to distribute tokens to
users sometimes you might not need to do
the fundraising part and you might just
want to distribute tokens to a wide set
of users how do you do that giveaway and
the the first example of an airdrop I
would argue one of the first was was
PayPal when they got started and he
signed up for PayPal you get ten bucks
of PayPal credits wasn't a token
obviously but they were saying we've got
a network we need people to use this
network we just need to give them a
little bit of money to get started they
can send some money you send it to a
friend pay for something and then
they're gonna get really addicted and
start to put more money in and that's
what an airdrop is it's a way of saying
and it worked it worked yeah you can
give tokens away to people they can
start to use on the network and then
hopefully they become such a fan of that
network that they put more of their own
capital in to use it so who amongst
start-up school world should think about
tokens as though as a way to kick-start
their network to raise funds potentially
and who shouldn't yeah so so today and
this is again where I differentiate
premier today and and you know tomorrow
or the future today I think the most
valuable applications of this technology
are applications where you have parties
are not willing to trust each other
they're not willing to trust each other
they don't want to trust a central
intermediary either and you to build
this trust --less system this does not
describe a lot of businesses but where
Trust is is somehow fundamental to the
functioning of whatever product you're
creating exactly so if we look at an
example that I would say is is a not a
great candidate for a token there's
possibilities but not a great candidate
would be Airbnb so on it on its face you
would say this actually sounds pretty
good I want to stay somewhere someone
out there I've never met before has a
home that I can stay in I don't trust
that person I've never met them before
I've got no connection to them but I do
trust Airbnb so you can have this
intermediary I've no problem trusting
Airbnb I stay in them all the time and I
say alright if the Airbnb is vetted them
and they're backing me up they've got
their insurance thing we've got all this
no problem I trust Airbnb let's do it
that means not a great candidate for a
token but if you start to have systems
where you don't trust even the
intermediary much less the person the
other side that's where a token might be
a good fit and the reason I'm not giving
a Russian version of Airbnb maybe maybe
you'd want a coin for the totally
possible or in it yeah absolutely
and Trust in institutions is is fading
there's all sorts of research on this
Edelman puts out a great survey on trust
every year and and and so there is an
idea that this could be more of a thing
in the future but the reason I'm not
answering your question with just a slew
of examples I can give you of like if
your business fits this do if your
business fits this to a token if your
business is because I just do not think
there are that many today and so it's
it's more about finding these very
specific use cases where it's
particularly valuable to have a token
than to try and fit into a category that
could have a ton of tokens coming out of
it I want to say some time for questions
but but just before we move on
you've talked in the past about pros and
cons of of tokens versus say
convertibles of various kinds like YC
safe that that probably most startups
used to raise money now both from the
the perspective of a start-up company
and from an investor maybe could could
we talk a little bit about those yeah so
you know everyone in here
you're in this class has done a lot of
thinking about traditional financing and
things like where you will if you have
it yes absolutely keep an eye out for
those lectures things like investor
protections what rights do investors get
how do you have to deal with them how do
you fundraise for them you sit down and
talk to them you follow up you do a call
there's all these things that go into a
traditional funder things we think about
with tokens a lot of that is flipped on
its head so probably the biggest
difference is that when you buy into a
token and this goes back to our original
discussion of what a token is the
company does not control the network in
this ideal form they release this
network and it goes out to the wild and
you own tokens on that network you own
part of that network but that means you
have no formal relationship to the
company as an investor in these tokens
and as a company technically you have no
formal relation to the investor that
owns your tokens and so there's this
idea right now in startups of you know
we talk good and bad investors like they
may call you they may check in you've
got an obligation to update them you've
got an obligation to get them to sign
documents at certain times and
transactions happen when people buy into
a token network released by a company
none of those obligations go and there
are pros and cons to that certainly on
both sides of the equation on the
startup side you know on one hand way
easier these people don't have any stake
in your business you can do whatever you
want with the company itself there's no
control that they have there the
downside of that is they are not
necessarily aligned with you so the
upside of equity is that it's upside
when someone wins with equity everyone
wins with equity in the in the general
case obviously there's some some edge
cases but incentives are aligned and
that's that's awesome with tokens the
incentives of the investors are not
necessarily aligned with that of the
company so if the token is pumping up
for some reason of flying up the charts
an investor who invested a ton of money
doesn't have any lock ups on it they may
just say yeah I'm getting out I'm up 10x
right now that seems totally worth it
I'm getting out and they dump it and it
hurts the price and it hurts the company
by kind of second-order effect there and
so you get this kind of misalignment you
win because they don't have any stake in
your company but you lose because they
don't have any stake in your company and
from the investor perspective the exact
flipside of that which is on one hand
you're not obligated to the company at
all you can do whatever you want you
just own tokens on a network they've
released but the other side of that is
that you might not get as much
visibility into what's happening
get those monthly updates you might not
be as engaged with the foundries you may
have never met the founders the idæan
startup fundraising of raising of people
that you've never met before does not
really happen that much occasionally you
see a little bit with certain things but
and you usually advise against it
usually advise against it in token world
you know many of these sales have had
hundreds or thousands of investors that
just signed up on the website
you know coinless facilitates this
people come and invest in sales where
they have never met talked to you can go
to coin lists right now and sign up for
token sales you certainly can you can
only participate if you're an accredited
investor unfortunately site regulation
sadly but but yes you may have no
relationship to the founders again pros
and cons on on both sides there yeah
it's kind of amazing from an investor
perspective because if you invest in a
startup company usually before you see
any return it's a lot of time five ten
years but with a token if the token goes
up tomorrow you can you can invest and
sell the next day right now do you think
we are converging tokens again our young
repeat this myself all the time there is
such a young industry they are
converging a little bit more towards
venture capital we're starting to see
vesting schedules and lockups for
investors trying to get this incentive
alignment a little bit tighter than kind
of the freest version that I was just
describing and I think a lot of its
gonna converge that way you know early
in the ico market companies raised once
they said we're gonna raise one monster
token sale that's gonna be it will never
need to fundraise again more and more
we're seeing people talk about kind of
stage things that start to look a lot
more like a traditional seed Series A
Series B and so it's gonna look more
like venture capital future I think but
there's still going to be these key
differences of what it is that you're
buying and what that means for the
relationships between the people
involved awesome so in the time
remaining if there's any questions on
any of the topics we've talked about
okay right here in front room
[Music]
I have two questions one about venture
investors you said good investors if you
could share with us like three big
points okay okay hang out there we'll
get we'll take each one and turn so what
are um what are the characteristics of
good investors in your view yeah so talk
about a couple characteristics and a way
to find out the characteristics that I
think are really important for investors
is one alignment with whatever your
goals are as an entrepreneur not
everyone's goals in this room are going
to be exactly the same some people might
be saying for me this is a ten billion
dollar business or bust that is it that
is all I'm going for and I will always
make the decision that leads towards
that outcome others might say listen if
I built a ten million dollar a year
revenue business I would be super happy
and I'm looking for investors for that
if investors are not aligned with that
goal you're going to be in big trouble
because you will eventually make a
decision that runs exactly counter to
what they want and so you need to make
sure they're aligned with you on that
second how you interface with them is
the interaction friendly it can be
intense they may do diligence and maybe
some real back-and-forth and firing back
and forth but do you walk away feeling
good after your interaction with them if
you do not that is not a good sign
because you are talking to them at a
time when it's supposed to be really
positive you're talking about joining
forces a one plus one equals three
situation if you're walking away and
saying this does not feel totally right
that's a really bad science at some
point in all likelihood hate to break it
to you things will not go perfectly I'm
not saying the business gonna shut down
or anything but you will have a tough
time at some point and if an investor is
not great when things are good or you're
talking about possible ways to work
together and build something amazing
they will be really bad when things are
going poorly and so I'd watch out for
those those are kind of my two biggest
things the last one is people argue
about this all the time but the idea of
value add I don't think every investor
has to be some sort of crazy perfect
they're gonna make some amazing
difference in your business but if
they're aligned and you need capital and
they believe it's a good investment that
can be fine you don't necessarily need
someone that's going to do everything
but when you can find those investors
obviously that can make that
introduction for you give you that
customer feedback whatever it may be
recruit someone that's tremendously
valuable the the last thing I would say
on that is that
super underrated part of fundraising is
due diligence and reference checks on
investors so few people do this but it
is amazing you talk to an investor
you're getting towards it you're saying
Jeff I think we've got a great
relationship here I'm really excited
about working with you I think we could
do something amazing and I would I would
love to work with you as one of my
investors um is it cool can I talk to
some people that you've invested in
before I just want to go since you're
working style and kind of like how we
could work together in the future now
first of all they say no to that
really bad signal right anytime someone
says no to reference check bad signal
they'll probably say yes and talk people
that he sends you maybe talk a couple
other people that you know he's invested
in that he didn't send you and just ask
them those questions because every
founder that's head an investor can give
you a very intuitive gut check on Jeff's
amazing he was actually their darkest
days like things were tough he came into
the office helped us figure out product
stretch this happened that happened and
then you go back to him and you say to
him you have I'm even more excited now
because I talked a bunch these people
and they said you were so helpful on
this you were so helpful on that I let's
make this happen that's the most
exciting way to close an investor
conversation highest chance close to the
money and you've now set expectations or
on what you hope the relationship will
be like and so I definitely do those
calls it takes time but it's worth it
for investor that you're looking at work
so that was a that was a solid gold
answer so please please please pay
attention pay Andy's wisdom there yes
okay so the question is given the
nuclear winter of in crypto land is
coinless looking to pivot to stos
or are you going to stick firmly with
icos yes so to unpack that a little bit
sto is a security token offering and
this goes back to what we're talking
about before around the blockchain and
token infrastructure being something
that you can build a lot of different
things on one of those things that
people talk about is what's commonly
called a security token or an
asset-backed token and this is an idea
of taking an existing asset something
that exists in the real world the
traditional world
maybe startup equity real estate maybe
gold bars whatever it may be and
building a token that represents that
asset so one token equals you know one
percent of this building or this
buildings revenue streams whatever it is
and and the question is you know we
looking to support those where
traditionally we supported i COS of
these tokens that are more kind of token
networks that only exist in the network
itself and not in the actual I guess you
could do an IC o---- of an STL it's
really it's like it's a little totally
so that's right where I'd go on that is
that um we are certainly looking to
support offerings of security tokens we
don't see that as a pivot we actually
see ourselves as just infrastructure to
support sales of tokens thus far they've
happened to be what are commonly called
protocol tokens where these kind of
Network tokens and they function on
these on these networks alone if the
tokens were offering our asset-backed
instead of network backed that makes no
difference to us as the platform we just
have to figure out if it's a good fit
for our investor base and if you know
that can happen but ultimately the
process for running those sales is
exactly the same awesome yeah
our tokens currency regulatory answer
totally depends practical answer yes and
no in the kind of colloquial form of
currency where you're using something to
exchange for something else absolutely
most of these tokens are some sort of
object fits into that category some
might not be so one example often refer
to bitcoins value as a store of value
and that means some really think of
Bitcoin most analogous to digital gold
gold is not a currency you can use it to
exchange for things but it's not really
great for that it's more used to store
value put value into it you take value
out of it and that's how I see the value
of Bitcoin I don't think it's the same
for every token more of these tokens
fall into that an exchange category but
from a regulatory standpoint of
colloquial definition the answer largely
is no to that but in certain cases maybe
yes again depending on the exact
characteristic so we could talk about
specific examples and bitcoins
complicated because there's Bitcoin cash
which is maybe a currency totally
different token so Bitcoin cash but it's
a totally different currency although
yeah okay maybe maybe that's too much
yes
[Music]
if everybody did so if Airbnb started
today would they be a good candidate for
an ICO I don't think necessarily I again
I go back to I trust Airbnb I have no
problem with that and yes I'll go
forward and rent someone's house through
Airbnb and be happy with that there are
arguments that it could be successful in
that manner because maybe it's less fees
if there's less of a middleman but
Airbnb does provide valuable services to
me as the consumer and I'm willing to
pay for those services I don't feel like
Airbnb is taking unreasonable fees on
those transactions because they provide
a lot of services and so you know do
they need a network I don't think they
need one
could it be an interesting service could
be a potentially competitive service
absolutely but I if I were starting that
business today I wanted to connect you
know homeowners or apartment owners to
people that wanted to stay there I would
probably go the centralized route
initially but with an eye on the crypto
space and seeing if there might be
opportunities in the future the last
thing I would say on that is it is
underrated today how hard it is to build
these token networks it is so hard
they're so young the tooling is not
there
development is incredibly challenging
augur was really the first ICO that
officially launched in a big way three
years from there ICO to launching they
just launched this summer and the amount
of work that went to that is
unimaginable I mean you have to replace
the human beings at air and be Airbnb
who are building the processes and
infrastructure to make it a trusted no
precedent for how to build these things
and so you know even that alone you're
looking at it as a business trying to
you know raise as little money as
possible and push forward of what you
have it's a tough move but do you think
it's fair to say that there's a faction
of crypto world that says central
authority bad and we should replace all
of those with a network a trusted
Network absolutely and I think a lot of
crypto has its roots in this kind of a
narco libertarian philosophy that I
think was incredibly important for the
early days of crypto because that is one
of its core use cases this avoidance of
middlemen and driving the industry
forward with that philosophy is
incredibly important but that's very
different from looking at it from a
a really pragmatic from this side and
there may be some crossover there but
it's not 100% right over there
[Music]
one question at a time because it's
really fun to pile them on but there's a
lot of people who want to ask questions
so ask them that's the one you really
want answered first how do you
distinguish between value and
information yes it's a really important
question I think at its core you can
represent value in information right so
I can make online transactions with the
internet without tokens and move value
around but what that's really doing is
moving symbolic representations of value
around and directing different entities
to move it so when I make a payment with
my credit card on the Internet sure it
is just information that is moving I'm
sending authorization codes my CVV goes
here and this happens but ultimately
what happens is it goes to one issuing
it the credit card issuing entity and
conveys them the information and II just
spent $10 on this merchant please debit
$10 or you know put $10 on a nice
balance and then merchants please here
are $10 you have now been paid for your
services what didn't happen there the
internet did not actually transmit that
value those entities on either side push
the value from one to the other they may
have done it over the bridge of the
internet but they were the ones that
were maintaining the value what's
interesting with this token ecosystem is
that the value is actually totally
contained in the network there are no
entities that are actually holding that
value for you there's no credit card
issuer that is keeping an eye on my
balance and taking payments for me and
there's no bank on the other side that
is holding on to the the merchants money
instead all the values representing the
network and people actually own that
value so I have my own keys on that
network I own those tokens or I own the
representation of those tokens I'm not
just owning information that gives me
access to someone else owning that value
so at the end of the day going just a
single player example my bank account
it's my money but it's not really my
money the bank has the money and I just
have information that allows me to
access that money in the world of tokens
I actually have ownership of that that
is those are my tokens because I have
the keys to access that and no one else
can do anything with it aside from me
who has that
access and so when we talk about
transmitting value as opposed to
transmitting information it's about
direct interactions between nodes I can
pay Jeff with tokens and it never
touches a third party at all
where's with information it requires
those third parties where you're
informing them to move money between
each other yes so this is I guess more
of a comment on the rigidity of networks
once you put them out there it's hard to
then go and change them and upgrade them
and make them backward compatible to
other things do you agree with that yes
and no I think again early days so there
hasn't been a lot built around the
upgrade ability of these networks and
once you put them out there it's harder
to make those changes especially
breaking changes there's more and more
infrastructure being built that supports
that it's something that I'm not
incredibly concerned about in the future
it's something that feels inevitable
that will get to a place where these
networks can be easily upgraded at the
same time goes back to this idea no
company controls that Network and so
they can't dictatorial II make that
change if they make a change and the
users on the network don't agree with it
the network will do what's called
forking we could talk for hours about
this where you get to difference and
this is where the Bitcoin Bitcoin cash
piece came in you know Facebook makes a
change I can't just like make a new
Facebook that goes back to the old
change that doesn't work I don't have
access to all of Facebook's
infrastructure and code in the crypto
world if you know say Protocol Labs me
to change the file coin that people
didn't like it would be totally possible
for people to start back right before
that change happened with the entire
history of transactions with all the
code and make a new version of Pyla coin
by coin cache and it's out of file it's
out of protocol ABS
wholly controls yep so as you vote again
goes back to this incentive alignment
thing that sure maybe someone has can
write to this version of the protocol
and make changes to it but they have to
make sure that all the users are aligned
from an incentive perspective to
participate on that same network going
forward instead of forking it or not
because you can fork and
then that fork is then
backwards-compatible and the new one
isn't it or vice versa and so maybe it's
easier because of the ability to fork
absolutely yeah more questions over
there is it possible for the someone
who's a node a person who's part of the
network to propose a change that then
gets incorporated into the network yeah
absolutely so any one node or otherwise
can try to fork a network and create a
new version of it with a with a change
there's again no special control that
these companies have over these networks
other than some sort of moral authority
right if they created the network I
probably trust them to be kind of the
best stewards of that network and know
how to build it they're probably the
biggest experts onyx they built in the
first place so you're gonna probably go
with their version until there's a
reason not to and as soon as there's a
reason not to which could either be
because they do something bad or because
because someone else proposes something
better they could be going on a great
path and making a great product but if
someone else in other node anyone in
this room says I've got an improvement
to Bitcoin I think it's to be better
than what the existing core developers
are doing I'm gonna propose that I'm
going to align people around it and get
people's attention around it that could
for can be more successful and it's
totally up to that person to do so let
me argue that for a sec please isn't it
true that to really let these these
these decisions become somewhat
democratic and so the network decides
but isn't it also true that these
companies that that do i SEOs and and
are the creator of a token tend to hold
a significant portion of the currency
for themselves and therefore have the
biggest voice on the network yeah so a
couple things one is when I'm answering
these kind of high-level questions about
crypto I'm thinking purely of the good
the very small set of good tokens there
are lots of bad actors out there that
build in all sorts of weird ways to
influence the network but just talk
about the kind of ideal of these tokens
and blockchain networks that's where
we're going on these on these questions
absolutely some of these issuers have
significant stakes in the network but a
couple things happen to one the voices
are not always based on who is the
biggest stake in the network
you know a really important voice is
whoever is is mining and this is a whole
nother topic for what the consensus
mechanism is so on Bitcoin the Bitcoin
core developers there's a group of
people that have kind of access and can
try and change the code of Bitcoin but
it has to be adopted by all the miners
which of these people running huge
server farms doing work on the Bitcoin
network if those people choose not to
adopt it even if they've you can think
of a Bitcoin core developers as being
from the entity that created Bitcoin
which isn't really true in that case
again created by a pseudonymous Satoshi
Nakamoto but you know the the the miners
have the power they're not the people
that are kind of core developing it and
so it depends on again how the how the
network makes it so it's complicated it
is complicated okay a couple more
questions right there yeah so what what
develops would I expect to see in the
ico industry before they become a viable
path for more startups it really depends
on and again this goes back to it's a
really good question what we mean by so
when we say ICO we're talking about
Mitchell coin offering when we say coin
or token what are we talking about and
that's where it's it's so many different
things so what we've really been talking
about here is a history of successful or
you know looking to be successful
protocol tokhes these tokens that are
network based that have have this trust
avoidance our trustless networks I don't
think there's a world where every
startup is going to need to do that I'm
you know I trust my corner store to give
me good food I trust my guru you know so
that that will always exist and so I
don't ever think that every company will
need to do a token of that blend but you
can imagine a world go back to the SEO
question where there are tokens that
represent company equity and I am
purchasing company equity via a token
instead of some other document than
equity round or safe or whatever it may
be and maybe it's it there's an
underlying safe below it and there's a
token that represents it for that to
happen I think what we'll need to see is
just a lot more infrastructure we built
out there's reasons that that is a good
idea to have these asset backed tokens
things like increased access to
liquidity there's all these exchanges
being built and liquidity pools for
increased liquidity for these asset
backed tokens they're interoperable with
each other so you can move them around
more easily I think
was the trend Jeff and I've talked about
before generally the arc of venture
capital bends towards increased
liquidity and speed to liquidity and
these things come faster and faster a
little bit of a speed bump in recent
years but generally I think moving that
way and tokens will only continue that
trend so I do think as infrastructure
gets built out it may make sense for
companies to raise equity with tokens
that represent that equity and that is
not some sort of crazy ico phenomenon
will you be able to go out as a seed
stage startup and say you know my token
is worth 200 million dollars no it's
it's gonna represent the equity and
it'll be worth what the equities worth
maybe with some premium for the benefits
of tokenization on top of it but we need
infrastructure there and until that
infrastructure exists I don't think it's
worthwhile except as maybe a proof of
concept for people to show that it's
possible but we need more built there
and hopefully that gets built in the
coming months or years great one more
question right here yeah do I think the
futures gonna be a handful of block
chains are hundreds of block chains and
you know I think it'll be a relatively
small number of block chains but a
relatively high number of tokens and to
explain that for just a minute here many
of these token networks allow for other
tokens to be issued on top of it most
common buzzword you'll hear aetherium
which is the second biggest
cryptocurrency out there it's got a
blockchain the ethereum blockchain and
they've created standards on top for
theorem to issue other tokens on top of
ethereum and the one you'll hear a
tossed around a lot is in ERC 20 token
this is a token that is issued on top of
the etherium blockchain
but represents something other than
aetherium and its price is not
necessarily correlated with that of
aetherium I don't think there's a need
for hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of block chains to exist because they
are a pain to maintain you need to all
these users on it you know with
different mechanisms for how they
interact with each other but I do think
we're gonna have a world with a lot of
different tokens maybe not as many as
some people think I'm not kind of a
tokens for everything but if we get to
this world of asset-backed tokens where
all of a sudden buildings could have
tokens to represent their ownership or
companies kind of tokens represent their
ownership
that's a lot of tokens that are possible
out there but they will they will not
all have their own block chains that
would likely be built on something which
will be very error-prone if they do
right because because it's all new code
and there's a brace for it to be safe
and secure and so maybe they'll all be
on ethereum or stellar or one of these
other networks but lots of tokens
relatively few block chains would be my
prognostication the last point I would
make on that is once again we are less
than a decade into crypto at all we are
less than five years into tokens beyond
you know the very basic building blocks
at all that is the earliest earliest
days imaginable of this ecosystem and
any prediction that makes day stands
probably a worse chance of being true
than than a good one so who knows we'll
see you the next day in the coming
decades that's great wait and thank you
very much for your time and thank you
thank you guys
[Applause]
you